Riverdale star Ryan Grantham has been
sentenced to life in prison for killing
his mother according to multiple reports
the 24 year old actor was reportedly
sentenced at British Columbia Supreme
Court in Vancouver on Wednesday reports
state that he will not be eligible for
parole for 14 years he told the police
he did it
to protect me but it wasn't him Grantham
started acting when he was six years old
his last gig an appearance on Riverdale
so sorry he's also recognized for his
role in the 2010 family comedy Diary of
a Wimpy Kid
[Music]
Grantham previously pleaded guilty to
second-degree murder after shooting his
64 year old mother Barbara wait in the
back of the head while she was playing
piano in March 2020. new details
surfaced during a hearing in June when
prosecutors claimed the actor confessed
to the crime on video which was shown in
court prosecutors also accused Grantham
of plotting to kill Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau alleging that he
packed his car with three guns
ammunition 12 Molotov cocktails camping
supplies and a map with directions to
Rodeo Cottage in Ottawa where the
politician lives prosecutors claimed
Grantham started the 50-hour drive to
Ottawa with the intention of killing
Trudeau but changed his mind and turned
around alleging that he contemplated
committing an act of violence at Simon
Frazier University where he had been a
student according to the BB see Grantham
ultimately decided to drive to a
Vancouver Police Station where he
allegedly confessed to an officer quote
I killed my mother he's extremely
remorseful for his actions and
he's doing everything he possibly can to
make amends for them law enforcement
officials in Vancouver explained to
deadline that Grantham has been in
custody since 2020 with sources adding
that he's been participating in mental
health programs since his arrest during
the third and final day of his June
hearing Grantham reportedly said quote
it hurts me to think about how badly
I've wasted my life in the face of
something so horrible saying sorry seems
so pointless but from every fiber of my
being I am sorry
foreign